we can argue who about who's really
responsible for inflation dropping but
this is a significant slowdown uh as you
said it it has slowed from 6.7% on the
year in September to
4.6% uh on the year in October and the
main reason for that is that a lot of
that um energy data that huge surge in
energy cost from last year has now
fallen out of the figures and instead
it's reflecting the fact that off gem
the energy regulator actually lowered
the price cap more recently so you're
now taking into account much better data
much better costs on energy so we've
seen that significant drop I should note
that core inflation which excludes those
more volatile prices like energy and
food is still significantly higher
around
5.7% um that suggests that a lot of this
inflation has really ingrained itself
into the system prices are higher of
course the inflation rate being at 4.6%
overall means prices are still going up